yes somebody was talking about being a
golden age yesterday or have you watched
Peter Pan probably fathered that form
did you watch any Disney movies during
the Golden Age of Disney I'm talking
about Little Mermaid have you ever seen
no is it a rat I think it might be a rat
really dad have you can you look at
brother
yeah look it up bro sand dollar what's
that guy's name sand dollar bill yeah
those are Buffett right there that's
rikki-tikki-tavi the real oh it's
Richard crippling it was a rat fighting
a snake oh he's there am I the right I'd
rather be a snake yeah and you're the
one that's being devoured yeah how's
that be rats have nine lives you [ __ ]
creep I'll be all what you want to say
huh
what you want to say crank but it didn't
make any sense you know yeah Oh to hear
this yeah chappie so just couple of
glasses
my girlfriend's connect my girl wants to
ask you hitting each other have you seen
the Little Mermaid yes
have you seen Aladdin yes have you seen
Lion King yes Milan No okay let's fair
three out of cours maybe not the Asian
yes I saw almost various Disney movie
yeah amazing
don't roll yeah yeah yeah if you don't
want to go no don't row um but that was
a brutal movie yeah but she's giving me
[ __ ] because um I know the story
tell me I'll tell you the story right
now it's Cinderella Cinderella okay
Chris friend who are her friends
Cinderella's Prince Jim
Cinderella had a lot of friends my pots
oh no that's beauty in the beasts
that's chip-chip nazi pot yeah yeah yeah
she has animals the talk teapots also
feel like every Asian rappers name but
the story of Cinderella is the
Cinderella is that she is missing a shoe
yeah was you missing a shoe where is she
yeah right there was another offer
enemies that the witch Wicked Witch of
the wheat with her stepsisters good evil
stepsisters
there's no Wicked Witch and they judged
her know why that's know why yeah well
let's go to snow white then one of the
dwarves
Austin slappy no another white skin
gypsy no no zippy no Sippy's an
alcoholic Oh was one of them alcoholic
why don't drink a lot one of them did
drink a lot actually no the bubbles
sneezy
Obito that's what I was meeting dopey
yeah yeah slanty no those [ __ ] slanty
took nippy it's two doors stuck together